[Musique]
je sais ce que vous vous dites et ce mec
il a la classe il a même la classe
internationale et oui parce que la
classe internationale c'est ici qu'elle
s'exprime sur Radio Campus à Orléans
Viviane Maxime et Hassan depuis 12 ans
font grouver leurs auditeurs
depuis 12 ans en leur offrant des
voyages Sénégal Ghana Brésil ou encore
Cuba aujourd'hui c'est moi qui vais
intégrer ce collectif de passionnés pour
les faire grouver à ma façon c'est à
dire
enrouler bref
[Musique]
ça ça c'est une radio Campus ça me
rappelle mes années d'étudiants
regardez-moi ça des photos partout
bonsoir bonsoir à tous la classe
internationale l'émission des groupes du
monde 21h minuit sur Radio Campus
bonsoir les amis bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue à la classe internationale
Radio Campus dont je prends je prends
les commandes de l'émission j'ai quand
même à vous dire que faire venir à 49
sur un campus étudiant sans lui prévenir
que tous les souvenirs qui vont remonter
ça c'est moi donc comment ça a démarré
pour vous l'aventure ici ça fait 12 ans
que vous êtes là comment ça a démarré
dès le début Radio Campus c'est
spécialisé dans le fait de passer ce
type de musique du groove international
sans être ce qui passait sur toutes les
radios en fait cette émission c'était
d'évidence quoi c'était un moment donné
on s'est dit oui on passe la musique
mais aussi on peut en parler quoi donc
voilà ça fait 12 ans que ça dure la
curiosité musicale c'est ce qui nous a
vraiment amené là vraiment à l'explorer
ce qui se fait dans le monde voir que
l'Occident n'est pas la seule source de
musique et dans notre recherche on
allait très très loin je peux te dire
c'est à dire jusqu'au bout dans la
rivière trouver du groove des îles du
Pacifique quoi du fin qui est il y a du
fun quand on a disco asiatique pas
beaucoup du coup mais on a trouvé ça les
radiocampus ils ont gardé vraiment leur
âme leur identité en effet je pense que
l'identité elle est forte elle est
étudiante avant tout cultiver une
certaine curiosité peut-être un regard
critique sur sur l'actualité peut-être
aussi une envie de d'apprendre de
transmettre de partager vous êtes
combien en fait dans le crew on est six
je crois bon 7 même
sa sélection aussi ses goûts et puis son
histoire avec la musique vous en étiez
où dans l'émission là on en était au
moment où on passe des disques et on
Stéphane
en fait je suis arrivé au bon moment
c'est un freestyle au trombone c'est
comme sur skyrock le dimanche soir il
passe des trucs absolument freestyle
dessus
[Musique]
bon après cependant j'ai quand même
remarqué quelques faiblesses au niveau
des jingle donc j'en ai bosser
quelques-uns je vous propose après vous
prenez vous prenez pas c'est vous qui
vous c'est vous qui voyez c'est fan
Radio Campus hit music only
ah c'est pas mal
pour se quitter on se quitte quoi là
c'est Mr Big mouth et on se quitte avec
un petit morceau d'aphrobite on s'écoute
tout de suite Mister des house il est
très bien ton lancement
validé par la bosse
[Musique]